we turn to the phone lines right now and
he's one of my favorites it was again a
career highlight for me to sit with him
and the now emmy-nominated bill
belichick on the set of the NFL 100
all-time team show one of the voices of
football night in America and Sunday
Night Football and he and the rest of
the Pro Football Focus team will be all
over this draft right here on this
Sirius XM channel 211 starting at 7:00
Eastern Time on Thursday night he is
Cris Collinsworth how are you Chris I'm
good I think we set up Belichick so well
he got he got the Emmy nomination that's
kind of how you look at it well you know
what Chris there is an eye on Chris and
Collinsworth and rich and Eisen and I
think again we hoped we did our job
right he says do your job we did our job
so it was looking back on it now though
mmm how interesting was the dialogue and
the back and forth between Brady and
Belichick yes I mean it was it was it
was compelling you know I mean there was
clearly this issue floating about the
room and I mean you remember I could
barely stand it I mean I was like okay
okay this is not going at all right oh
okay do you ever wake up in the middle
of night Tom and go I'm Tom effing brain
man I won you a lot of Super Bowl you
should be do it you know and it was like
this like they both looked at me like
you dog you know but I can just remember
the feeling of this is this is maybe the
first time that they've actually been in
the room were conceivably this
conversation could be happening yes and
that they were both being honored with
one of the greatest honors that the game
could ever bestow on somebody and I know
that the Pro Football Hall of Fame is
that but so many Pro Football Hall of
Famers would come into the room after
that conversation Chris and look at the
board and think that they had already
had their fill of humbling
honors in their life and this was one of
them and I honestly I got the same
feeling about Brady and Belichick to
Chris but it was also even though it was
one of the last episodes that we the
last episode that we aired the
quarterback one it was the first segment
that we recorded of all of them and I
just thought maybe we just all weren't
in a flow yet but looking back I think
that the two of those guys probably had
never been on camera before together for
an honor that each one of them had a
huge role in playing for the other and I
don't know if they knew how to talk
about it quite frankly you know you know
and the reason that both of them are who
they are is that they don't take a lot
of time to sit and reflect right if
you're sitting and reflecting when Tom
Brady leaves Bill Belichick is retiring
if you're sitting and reflecting when
your contract is up with New England
you're certainly not going to another
team right you're gone all right I
played the loudest 40-something years
old that was enough I feel good about
myself and I'm gonna go retire to this
incredible life that Giselle and I and
the kids are gonna have and yet there's
something wound tightly within those two
guys that you say that's not true about
you know it's not true about either one
of them and I think it's almost
inconceivable now that both of them are
gonna feel some competitive pull to
outperform the other now that they're on
on separate teams now if you ask either
one of them that question I think they
both say you're out of your mind but you
know they're both going for the same
ring right I mean they're both going for
the same trophy and if one of them
should get it you know that's gonna
adjust that conversation - no doubt
about it Chris and and I guess just to
put a fine point on this using the
documentary that we just saw the first
two parts of on Sunday night in the last
dance and how difficult it is to keep
anything together certainly when it is
so very successful
and that Bulls team just for whatever
reason is we're learning just could not
be kept together Brady and Belichick for
all what we were talking about about
what might have been in the room at the
time last May they still did do it for
20 years together 20 years that will
never be matched in sports living NFL
and when you think about it in the grand
scheme of things obviously we have a
sixth round draft choice right on one
side but on the other side you have a
guy that had been fired by the Cleveland
Browns so I mean the whole thing you
know the unlikely nature of all of that
perfect storm coming together to do what
they remarkably did is a little
mind-boggling and I'm not sure we'll
ever ever ever see anything like it
again I just don't think that remote a
nod of a sixth round draft pick and a
guy who had been fired from another I
just can't see it ever happen he do Cris
Collinsworth Sunday Night Football and
pro football focus here on the Rich
Eisen show let's get to the draft you
and the guys at PFF have who is the
highest rated player going into this
draft in two nights oh I think Joe
burrows clearly the number one guy and
we're you know I think for the
Cincinnati Bengals you go back in their
history and you look at
they went to two Super Bowls I was lucky
to be a part of both Kenny Anderson
Boomer Esiason both won the MVP in a
year in which we went to the Super Bowl
Carson Palmer you know gave them good
runs and gave them opportunities and who
knows if he beats the Pittsburgh
Steelers in the game that he gets hurt
throwing a 60-yard bomb and and hurts
his knee on the play and the receiver
hurt his knee on the play as well who
knows because I think that was oh six I
think that was the year that the
Steelers went on to the Super Bowl and a
guy that nobody will ever remember Greg
cook was supposed to be the best
quarterback of all of them and hurt his
shoulder after a year or two or whatever
the case may be so I think Mike Brown is
certainly looking at this and go
you know I either have one of those guys
and you have a chance or you don't and
you don't and I've known him and been
around him long enough to know that
unless somebody drops at king's ransom
at his front doorstep he is he is going
with Joe burrow and taking a shot and
don't we just stick on the quarterback
front I mean two of the evaluation of
him for the last two years has just been
stellar we all know about the hip injury
and the fact that no I guess team doctor
has had been able to write before the
draft take a look at him and then look
at their coach and or general manager in
the eyes and the doctor say thumbs up we
don't have that so now it's an
evaluation of - OH - the locked-in
medical for your own team versus Justin
Herbert what about that evaluation in
your mind Chris you know a year ago at
this time it was tanking for tour right
yep and and they have three picks in the
first round and I think Miami may have
to in the second round as well so they
have more draft capital than anybody in
this draft the people at PFF will tell
you all my mathematicians that work on
this stuff and the equation is pretty
simple that the quarterback moves the
needle more than anybody else it's not
even close the winds above replacement
the war stuff and all the different
things it's not even close so let's say
that you draft to them you're considered
to it to be the best one and it's a
complete bust doesn't work out you still
have the 18th pick the 26th pick the
chute picks in the second round more
draft capital than anybody and two
tremendous quarterbacks coming one out
of Clemson one out of Ohio State the
following year that maybe you get a
chance to go for one of those III did my
mock draft and I tried every scenario to
take two out of number five at Miami and
I could not make it make sense
okay so let's say
because I've got Isiah Simmons going to
the giant do what anybody else does but
Andrew Thomas is is the you know my my
best offensive tackle Jedrek wills
Justin Herbert you know right down the
left of the guys Derek brown of the guys
that are going to come next is the
potential the potential now of what to
look could mean to that franchise is it
worth the shot that he comes back to
being the guy that we all thought just
you know ten months ago that he was that
kind of guy
to me it's still worth that that shot
now yeah I think that somebody else can
look at Justin Herbert and go that's the
real freak in this draft that's the six
foot six guy who can run for 7 for 8 and
you know has this cannon of an arm that
can get it anywhere you want to throw it
that's the poster child for the Miami
Dolphins or Los Angeles chargers going
forward and I can see that
unfortunately the PFF numbers and what
he did on the football field don't
measure up to that they don't measure up
to somebody going 3 4 or 5
you know even 6 7 whatever I put him at
I put him at number 7 to the Carolina
Panthers you know and I didn't do any
trades I didn't do any of that stuff
I think the LA Chargers are convinced
Anthony Lin is convinced that with Tyrod
Taylor that he's got a player that can
win Lamar Jackson's won the MVP a season
ago with a similar style of play and the
one thing that the Chargers have always
fallen on the sword not doing is fixing
this offensive line and I just look at
them as a left tackle away from being
able to compete they've got the
receivers and Keenan Allen Hunter
Henry's Austin next layer Mike wait you
go right down the list this is you know
they got the pass rushers with Bose and
Ingram this is a team they've got a
secondary they can absolutely play with
the Kansas City Chiefs with all the guys
they've got there now so if you look at
that you know I'm putting them at guard
I mean it with an offensive line and the
Chargers at six and I'm putting Justin
Herbert at seven you've got a whole new
look going on there Cam Newton is gone
that rule comes in they love the
downfield throws there's nothing Herbert
can't do so that's the way I play
interesting Cris Collinsworth here on
the Rich Eisen show and you can hear him
and the rest of the PFF crew Thursday
night 7:00 Eastern right here on Sirius
channel 211 and you can listen at home
with Amazon Alexa Google assistant or
every stream in your house that'll be on
Thursday night for draft night for the
moment a few more minutes left with you
Chris so why do you like Isaiah Simmons
for the Giants at four don't you think
they gotta go a line to protect daniel
Jones and certainly since gentleman's
pushed all his chips to the center of
that table to use a Giants phrase from
back in the day what do you think there
yeah you know I here's my problem with
that one I look at these five offensive
linemen as you know maybe we just do the
top four but I look at them as almost
being interchangeable
like I really if you gave me the choice
of Andrew Thomas
Jedrek wills worse interest in words
like you know you know Tristan were
Becton my Mekhi back that's the name of
my time
yep back then I'd be like okay I don't
really care you know I probably would
have back then down a little lower but
between you know the other three between
Thomas wills and worse
it doesn't make that big a difference
for performing but I think that in
Isaiah Simmons you get another one of
those freakish athletes you know and if
you love sake one Barclay our guys will
tell you never drafter running back
right you know that there it's the most
replaceable position and football but
obviously say Kwan Barclays a great
player and and that's where he's going
to go but if he went there then and
you've got interchangeable attack
and behind you try and trade down I
would if I were the New York Giants
because I think I could get one of those
guys down to you know 11 12 13 but if I
had to stay put I want to freak up there
and to me the freak in this draft is
Isaiah Simmons and then you'd have a
freak on offense a freak on defense and
go get your tackle in the second round
he'd still be better than what they have
before I let you go let's come full
circle and talk about again our
emmy-nominated friend Bill Belichick and
what you think the quarterback room is
gonna look like for New England after
this draft do you think he's got
something big planned again he doesn't
have the second rounder because it
belongs to Atlanta for that Mohamed Sanu
trade that just did not work out and
what turned out to be again remarkably
Brady's final year what do you think
Bill's got cooked up here in regards to
his quarterback room with the Stidham
and Hoyer being the only ones in it
right now going there I would love that
pressing it I can't I can't see Jameis
Winston going there I don't know why I
just can't you know the guy that I can
see going there
don't his Andy Dalton I mean we had we
had charlie weis on and a few weeks ago
he pegged he pegged Dalton then he says
that Dalton's the guy is what he said to
keep an eye on him and he could become
expendable in two days technically yeah
I I think that you're gonna see some of
these guys getting trained I think
there's going to be a lot of veteran
players get traded during the draft and
and Andy Dalton is the one that as you
look at the New England Patriots today
today with you know with what they've
got and Josh McDaniels and for the
players that I think Andy Dalton would
give them the better chance than Jared
Stidham the problem is and it's going to
be the same things true with all these
rookie quarterbacks or rookie players in
general is who knows how much time these
guys are going to get in camp or OTAs or
whatever to learn what they're doing I
mean you can almost make a case that
what difference does it make if you
draft a quarterback this year they're
not going to have time to learn what
they're doing to be a factor this year's
are you better off gunning for one next
year because we know there's two pretty
good ones coming out of there headlined
by Trevor Lawrence so you know it's it's
there are so many complicating factors
as you probably know getting ready for
your draft show now there's so many
complicating factors to this football
season and for the New England Patriots
you know I assume their thought is
they're gonna go with George Stidham or
with a veteran guy that they feel I can
plug and play into that system and for
me that players Andy doll Chris thanks
to the time always appreciate it and I
truly mean what I say that that what we
did last May at NFL Films for NFL 100
all-time team series I keep me and I'll
mention every single time he come on I
don't care it really was that special it
really truly was so I appreciate the
time as always in chatting with you
right back at you Chris Collinsworth
Sunday Night Football on NBC Sports and
again Pro Football Focus the PFF guys
and ladies are locked in hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here